How you doing sir?
I was doing great.
Tell me sir, are you a US citizen?
Am I being detained?
Excuse me?
Are you detaining me?
Are you one of those guys?
That's great, more citizens should know their
rights.
No sir you are not being detained,
I would need probable cause for that.
in fact, if you want to get technical, according
to Section 18.7
of the Border Patrol's Inspector's Field Manual
governing internal checkpoints,
I need have reasonable suspicion that you
are both an alien
and inside the country illegally before I
can detain you.
And then of course there are the numerous
Constitutional issues at play
which I'm sure you are aware of.
Do you have a copy of the pocket Constitution?
You don't have to answer that.
Here, why don't I just give you one of mine,
uh here's two actually, that one's in English,
this one's in Arabic if you need that.
Are you recording me?
Is that on?
Are you recording me right now?
Oh-
You don't have to answer.
No, according to the Supreme Court
Florida v. Royer, Terry v. Ohio.
You're well within your rights not to respond.
Truth is I shouldn't even be asking you about
anything not directly regarding your citizenship
but hey -- I won't tell if you won't ok?
Well, but you know you got me there, right?
You got me there, so here, here's what I'm going to do
I'm going to give you my card, right, it's
got my badge number at the bottom
and I wrote my direct supervisor's email on
the back there.
So if you have any questions at all, you just
contact us, okay?
You don't have to answer that either, you
have a good day sir.
It's cool -- I gave him a pocket Constitution.
I don't consent to searches!